sources tell CBS News at Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has made his plans
for 2024. what do you think he's decided
Ed O'Keefe is with us from Washington Ed
good morning this is a surprise I would
say to no one but what are you hearing
well Gail good morning two sources close
to Governor DeSantis tell CBS News His
official filing as a candidate is now
set to come next week the decision to
file the paperwork is set to coincide
with plans to meet with some of the
governor's long-time donors at a hotel
in Miami they're expected to be briefed
on plans for the forthcoming campaign
and requests that they start help
raising big money for the bid DeSantis
has been busy with fellow Republicans in
Florida passing a conservative set of
legislative priorities on Tuesday in
Tampa for example he signed a bill that
expands on the state's so-called don't
say gay Bill notably CBS News polling
shows the governor is doing exactly what
Republican primary voters want by
challenging so-called woke ideas
opposing gun restrictions and making
liberals angry among other things we
started getting hints of the upcoming
campaign last weekend during his trip to
the early caucus state of Iowa where a
bus was spotted that red joined team
DeSantis for president with the slogan
Never back down once they start putting
it on vehicles you know what's real now
polling suggests that Santos is
Comfortably owning the second place spot
behind former president Donald Trump and
the GOP field is set to get even more
crowded South Carolina Senator Tim Scott
is expected to launch his campaign next
week and we're still waiting on
decisions from former vice president
Mike Pence and New Hampshire Governor
Chris sununu among others Tony
Ed I think I got it now once they start
putting it on vehicles then you know
it's real it's a good sign
yeah I think yeah they're pretty
reliable there team DeSantis somebody at
the body shop knew this was coming okay
I got a tip appreciate it